Speaker 1: Failed. Former President Donald
Trump, once arrested, twice impeached,
has been indicted a second time, this time
federally. He will be arrested and booked
on Tuesday in Miami at 3 p.m. Eastern Time.
Ladies and gentlemen, it is happening and
it is even more unprecedented. If you can
if you could even say such a such a thing.
Wow, what a day. What a night. CNBC Report
ex-President's Arraignment comes day before his
birthday. Donald Trump has become the first U.S.
president, former or otherwise, to be indicted
on federal criminal charges. Trump announced on
Thursday night posts on his truth social platform
that prosecutors notified his attorneys. He had
been indicted, NBC News confirmed soon after that
he faces seven charges, including making false
statements, conspiracy to obstruct, according to
Trump's own lawyer, James Trusty. The charges
also include willfully retaining documents in
violation of the Espionage Act. Trump, the leading
contender for the GOP presidential nomination,
is scheduled to appear Tuesday at a federal
courthouse in Miami. The former president had
kept reams of classified documents in boxes at his
Mar a Lago resort in South Florida until federal
agents raided it last year and seized the records.
Trump says he's innocent and ripped the case as a
hoax. It is very important to understand a number
of distinctions between this and what is happening
with the indictment and arrest in New York. The
New York arrest is on state charges. This is
a federal indictment. This is not necessarily
the only federal indictment that Donald Trump
is facing because this is only related to the
documents. There is also a federal investigation
going on into Donald Trump's role in inciting
the Trump riots of January six, 2021. No charging
decision has been made there, and at minimum,
there are additional state charges possible
against Donald Trump in the state of Georgia.
We will learn more about that sometime between
I believe the dates are July 11 and September
1st or July 1st and September 11th, something
along those lines. None of this none of this is
at this time evidently politically motivated,
a witch hunt, a perversion of the justice
system or anything like that. We're going
to delve into those aspects and details.
But Trump indicted federally. Historic
days in the United States. Let's
now go to Donald Trump's reaction.